Ryan's in Fargo North Dakota I Ryan how
are you Dario better than I deserve
what's up hey so I'm just curious what I
should be doing with my money I have a
little under thirty thousand of my
savings between I'm twenty-two by the
way between my three 401ks I have right
around twenty five thousand and I make a
little under fifty thousand a year and
I'm just curious what what what should I
be doing what am I steps going forward
where'd that money come from
what money which which one well I mean
you're 22 years old you make $50,000 a
year how'd you end up with twenty
thousand bucks in your 401k and twenty
thousand bucks in your savings tool it
over to my second two years it's great
it's wonderful I just those nerves don't
have I mean did you inherit some money
do are you do you live at home and have
no expenses or no no I rent I I don't
know I guess I just say I was very
fortunate I'm in the service and so I
got a good-paying job pretty much right
out of high school with the military oh
okay okay so you've been working in the
military since high school okay that
makes a little more sense that's four
years or four years to do this okay good
good for you okay and your question then
is what again what do i what am i steps
going forward like obviously getting a
house I don't have any debt so I'm
curious is there was there a certain HP
investing money or using my money there
or I think you're doing a really really
good job overall okay I think you've
done a fabulous job for twenty-two years
old most guys your age that have spent
four years in the military don't have
nothing and you know that because they
just spin it off and so you've done a
good job managing your money whatever
you're doing do more of that that's why
I was asking you but the we teach a
financial planning process that's very
popular because it's very clear and it's
called the baby steps baby step one is
to save $1,000
you've done that to is to be debt-free
you've done that except your home baby
step three is to have a fully funded
emergency fund which is three to six
months of expenses set aside for rainy
days not to be touched for anything
except major emergencies and what and
you make fifty thousand so of your 20
something thousand that's in savings
probably set aside about fifteen
thousand of that over in a separate
money market account never to be touched
it's just there if you have a major life
problem like a layoff a transmission
that goes out some big expense that
there's no way you could see coming okay
it's not saving up to buy something it's
just sitting there to protect you when
life happens
it's your contingency fund you're god
only knows fund
okay now that leaves us seven thousand
there plus you're doing money in your
401 K then we move on to baby steps four
five and six four is put fifteen percent
of your income into retirement plans you
need to start doing that immediately and
baby step five is saved for your kids
college it sounds like you're not
married and don't have kids okay and so
you you know you don't have kids you're
not married you don't have to do baby
step five kids college baby step six is
pay off house earlier you haven't bought
the house yet so what I would do is I
would start saving fifteen percent of
your income into retirement
if you want to use the thrift plan
that's fine I'd put eighty percent in
the sea and ten percent in the eye and
ten percent in the S and if you're going
to do that if you're not just do Roth
IRAs either one is fine but do the Roth
version of the thrift plan the TSP and
then but above don't put more than
fifteen percent that's the maximum above
that starts saving for your down payment
on your house and you've already got
seven thousand dollars if yet you said
you had twenty two in savings right okay
okay we put fifteen aside for your
emergency fund in my example that I'm
doing with you okay and that leaves
whatever the balance is in that account
as a game
start on your down payment for the house
so I start putting 15% of your income
aside in your budget
start doing a written budget every month
use that every dollar app I was just
talking about before I picked up with
you and you know start your 15% towards
retirement you've already been doing
something because you got money in a
401k but just look at your income you
need about 7,500 dollars a year that's
15% of 50,000 going into retirement and
then above that any money we can squeeze
out of the budget we just add to that
other account that downpayment house
down payment account and finish saving
up for a house and put as much down as
you can put down and then pay the house
off as fast as you can lean into it and
get get it done good question ma'am
thank you for joining us